bonsoir bernard tapie soir merci d'avoir
accepté notre notre invitation
dans la nuit du 3 ou 4 avril dernier il
ya trois semaines
quels souvenirs gardez-vous de cette
nuit là je pourrais vous dire que la
seule façon d'arriver à passer au dessus
de cet événement c'est surtout pas en
faire à souvenirs
et comme ma femme nous regardent et
qu'elle est traitée
parce qu'elle a beaucoup de mal harvey
cet événement toutes les nuits si ça
vous dérange pas j'aimerais bien qu'on
n'en parle pas la seule chose que je
veux me permettre de dire c'est que il y
avait une haine dans leurs oeufs dans
leur façon de parler de dia de faire ta
gueule
c'était pas à tétouan à c'était ta
gueule vous sentez que ça on était
qu'elle tient à battre alors c'est fort
il faut en parler mais ils n'ont pas le
camp même un petit peu vous trouvez que
non non parce que je trouve la personne
n'oblige bernard tapie à quoi que ce
soit depuis le début et compris
maintenant et compris même malgré sa
maladie c'est un type qui est
exceptionnel franchement il l'a encore
prouvé hier
non mais quand on vous dit et bernard
tapie mais vous croyez franchement le
nom mais bernard tapie c'est quelqu'un
qui connaît la télévision c'est
quelqu'un quand il prend un engagement
il le tient
et quand bernard taille conduit le
boulot lui dit on a tout préparé
c'est impossible compliqué aussi de
leader oui mais une série non mais aussi
faut arrêter non d'abord on ne passe pas
il a passé une heure une heure et quart
donc s'ils étaient ils avaient embarqué
il serait parti au bout d'un quart
d'heure
deuxièmement gilles verdez faut arrêter
quand même devenir n'importe quoi
franchement chaque fois que je viens ici
j'ai affaire à un con comme vous et je
vais vous dire une chose chaque fois je
j'ai un peu au bout et je vais vous dire
une chose je vais le répéter c'est pas
très gai ce n'est pas très raide raffiné
mais je vous rappelle pierre desproges
il y parlait à un conte ou essayer de le
convaincre c'est comme se masturber avec
une râpe à fromage beaucoup de
souffrance pour peu de résultats
[Rires]
e
[Applaudissements]
c'est des grands garçons n'avait pas
d'argument vous maniez l'insultent ou la
citation de pierre desproges incapable
alors on va prendre un autre a dit de
quelqu'un qui pense que il aurait oui
retardé gilles guillaume oui bien sûr
qu'il fallait reporter l'interview
bernard tapie reconnaît lui même il l'a
dit qu'il n'est pas en état de le faire
ça c'est pour la forme et sur le fond
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont un peu
piégé on a le sentiment qu'ils voulaient
pas du tout parlé de l'agression et
gilles bouleau première question c'est
sur l'agression bernard tapie dit je
veux pas en parler mais mal à l'aise
match m'a arrêté en gréco a créé de
l'interview ils se mettent d'accord
avant donc là à mon avis n'est pas au
courant mais attendez il n'était pas au
courant attendait il a fait une
interview au point il ya quelques jours
vous êtes journaliste bien aux gens dont
il avait 12 dont ton non pas français
dieu dans l'interview du point il a
parlé très longuement de lagdo sur la
grille il a parlé de l'agression de sa
femme qu'il a parlé
et moi je vais vous dire le lendemain le
lendemain de l'agression je la paie d'un
vieil ami je le connais depuis 35 ans je
lui dis qu'est ce qui s'est passé et là
je vous dire ce qui s'est passé parce
qu'il l'a dit et il me l'a dit et il a
pas et il m'a pas dit non on n'en parle
pas qu'est ce qui s'est passé il m'a dit
le truc le plus dur et que je ne
souhaite à aucun ennemi le pire c'est
que je suis attaché
ma femme est attaché d'un champ d'à côté
j'en entends hurler je ne sais pas ce
qui se passe et ça c'est vrai et audi et
je le souhaite à personne
et deuxièmement je le dis parce qu'il
faut aller jusque là il me l'a dit et il
m'a pas dit pour venir à bercoff garde
ça avec toi c'est pas le problème
il m'a dit il a parlé aux joueurs et
vous savez que tapie s'est toujours
illustré par son combattre contre jean
marie le pen et pour les immigrés etc
il a vu il a dit un des types qui était
là il a parlé une fois comme ça il le
dit mais je comprends pas des gens comme
vous je me suis battu pour des gens
comme vous pourquoi vous m'attaquez à
moi et le type lui répond va te faire
[ __ ] ce temps-là est mort voilà
textuellement les mots de merlin taper
le rapport il avait la droite pas
vouloir en parler sur tf6 a peur parce
qu'il est affaibli
ça mais ça ne s'appelait bas et là
maintenant il a pris du recul et c'est
très bien qu'il ait pris du recul
alors mais on ne peut pas dire qu'on l'a
que gilles bouleau l'un porte qui l'a
forcé on le force pas bien ça se fait
très lourd de talent